[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: OK, why
don't I get started?
So OK, what have we been doing?
So last time, we
considered a bunch
of procedures for testing
properties of various automata
and grammars, the acceptance
problem for DFAs, for NFAs,
the acceptance problem,
which is really
degeneration problem for
context-free grammars,
and emptiness problems for
DFAs and context-free grammars.
And also, we showed that
A,TM is Turing-recognizable.
There's a question here in
the chat already about that.
Yes, we did show that.
That was the universal
Turing machine
that we presented at the end.
That's what shows that A,TM
is Turing-recognizable.
We mentioned that
A,TM is not decidable,
which we promised
we will prove today.
And we will do so.
OK, so that is the plan--
proving A,TM is undecidable.
And we'll introduce the
method for doing that called
the diagonalization method.
I will also show the
complement of A,TM is
Turing-unrecognizable.
Even though A,TM
itself is recognizable,
the complement is not.
And then we will introduce
another method called
the reducibility method for
showing other problems are not
decidable and give one example
of another problem, which
is not decidable, assuming
we have time to get to it.
If not, we will delay that part
until next Tuesday's lecture.
All right, acceptance
problem for Turing Machines.
So just as I mentioned,
we showed that A,TM,
which is the language of Turing
machines and inputs where
the machine accepts the input.
We showed that was recognizable.
We claimed it was decidable.
Today, we're going to
prove it's not decidable.
All right, now the method
that we're going to use,
which is really the
only method out there
for proving a problem
as undecidable
is called the
diagonalization method.
I mean, ultimately, we're going
to show the reducibility method
as well.
But it really depends
on having already
shown some other
problem undecidable
via the diagonalization method.
So ultimately, everything hinges
on the diagonalization method,
which is really what we have.
And so to introduce the
diagonalization method,
I'm going to make a
bit of a digression
into a branch of mathematics
called set theory
or it's a part of
mathematical logic, where
the method of
diagonalization was first
conceived of back in the late
19th century by a mathematician
called Georg Cantor.
And Cantor was considering
the problem of,
how do you compare the relative
sizes of infinite sets?
For finite sets, the problem
of comparing-- somebody
said that Cantor went crazy.
That is true.
And maybe I don't know
why he went crazy.
But he did go--
he had some mental
problems, unfortunately.
And so how do we compare the
sizes of sets in general?
If they're finite sets,
we can just count them up.
We can say, whoa, this
set has 11 elements,
and the other set
has 10 elements.
So the one with 11 is bigger.
Or if they both have 11,
they're the same size.
Well, that's not going
to work for infinite sets
because you can't count them up.
And so he had--
Cantor had the following
idea for comparing
the sizes of infinite sets.
And that was, basically,
to see whether you
can have a function
that would map
from one set to the other
set with certain properties.
And those properties are
called, traditionally, well,
I mean, in the past, have
been called the one-to-one
and onto properties
for the function.
I'll tell you what that means.
But the concept is very simple.
So a one-to-one
function is a function
that's mapping from A to B.
Those are the two sets whose
sizes we're trying to compare.
And the function
being one-to-one just
means that there
are no collisions.
If you have two
different elements of A,
they're never going to map
onto the same element of B.
So two different
elements of A always
map onto two different
elements of B.
So that's the
one-to-one property.
It's also called injective.
And the other property is
called onto or surjective,
which is that the range
of f has to be all of B.
So you're not allowed
to miss any elements,
but you have to hit everything.
And when you have both
of those properties,
the function is called a
one-to-one correspondence
or a bijection also, OK?
Now another way
of looking at it--
I don't want to make this
more complicated than it
needs to be.
It just simply
means that two sets
are considered to be the
same size if we can match up
the elements with one set with
elements of the other set.
You just pair them up.
For example, well, if you
have finite sets, that idea,
that informal idea just works
exactly as you would expect.
For example, if we have two
sets-- here's a set of puppies.
Here's a set of kittens.
Now we want to show that those
two sets have the same size.
We could count them up, as I
mentioned, and see that there
are six elements in both.
But counting up does not
work for infinite sets.
So we can just match up
the elements of the puppies
with the kittens,
and then we know
we have the same number
of puppies as kittens.
OK, now that has the
advantage of it making sense
when you have infinite sets.
So we're just going
to extend that idea
and apply it to
infinite sets too.
And then we'll have
a notion of what
it means for two infinite
sets to have the same size.
And you might wonder,
what do you get?
Are all infinite
sets of the same size
when you use this notion or not?
What happens?
Well, some strange
things do happen.
But there actually are quite
some interesting structure
there that emerges.
So anyway, I don't
want to rush on.
Questions on any of this?
If you want to--
quick question.
This, hopefully, was not too
hard, but I want to make sure
everybody's together with
me on it, so we can pop in--
I'll give a few seconds for a
chat if you have any questions.
The range of the set
is all of the elements
that you hit as you look at
the different possible elements
of A. So all of the things that
f hits, the standard notion
of a range of a function.
So the range of f
has to be equal to B.
You have to hit everything.
All right, can you think of
a one-to-one correspondence
as a relabeling?
Yeah, I'm not sure
that's helpful.
But, yes, you can think of as
a relabeling of the elements
in a sense, but yeah.
I just think of it
as a matching up.
All right, so let's move on.
So coming out of
this notion of sets
being of the same
size with this notion
of countable sets, as
we'll see in a minute,
so let's do an example.
Let's take the set
of natural numbers--
1, 2, 3, 4, dot, dot,
dot, dot, and the set
of integers, which includes
the natural numbers
but also the negative
numbers and zero.
So the natural
numbers are typically
referred to as N. The integers
are typically referred to as Z.
And what do we think of the
relative sizes of N and Z?
Well, N is a subset of Z.
It's a proper subset of Z.
So you might, at first glance,
think that Z is larger,
and they're not really going
to be of the same size.
But actually, it turns out that
there's a very simple way--
the arithmetic and the
properties of infinite sets
can be a little bit surprising.
And there is a way of matching
up all of the elements of Z
with their own elements
of N. And so you
can show that following that
definition, that these two sets
are, in fact, of the same size.
So let's just quickly go
make sure you see that.
So here is N. Here
is Z I'm going
to write down a table which
shows how they match up.
Here is the function f of n
that I'm going to be describing.
That's the one-to-one
correspondence.
And so here are the
natural numbers--
dot, dot, dot, 1 through
7, dot, dot, dot.
And here are the
elements of Z that I'm
going to be matching up.
This is how the
function is working.
So one, I'm going to--
f of 1 is going to be 0.
F of 2 is going to be minus 1.
F of 3 is going to be 1.
And I'm just giving
you a way to match up
each of the natural
numbers with integers
so that every single integer has
its own natural number and vice
versa.
So 4 goes to minus 2.
5 goes to 2.
6 goes to minus 3.
7 goes to 3, and then minus
4, and then 4, and minus 5,
and then 5, and so on.
You're clearly
going to cover all
of the integers in this way.
And each of the
natural numbers is
going to have its own integer.
And there's never going
to be any collisions.
There's never going to be
two natural numbers assigned
to the same integer.
So this meets the conditions
of a one-to-one correspondence
and shows that the natural
numbers and the integers
have the same size
following this definition.
OK, let's do one that's slightly
more complicated and, perhaps,
slightly more surprising,
which is that if you consider
all of the rational numbers,
and then they have the same--
that is a collection.
Even though the
rational numbers seem
to be much richer and more
numerous than the integers,
from this perspective,
they have the same size.
And for the simplicity
of my presentation,
I'm going to consider only
the positive rational numbers,
which I'm going to write as Q+.
So those are all of the
positive rational numbers
that can be expressed as a
ratio of two natural numbers.
And I'm going to show that there
is a one-to-one correspondence
between these positive
rational numbers
and the natural numbers.
OK, so here, I'm
going to, again,
make a table, just
as I did up above--
so comparing the
natural numbers and
the positive rational numbers.
And to do that, I'm going
to write down over here
on the side, just
to help you see
how I'm getting this table,
a separate table that
has all of the positive
rational numbers appearing
in a nicely organized way.
Here are all of the
rational numbers
here that have 1 as a numerator,
that have 2 as a numerator,
and so on, and going
through across the columns,
the different denominators.
So the numbers
inside here represent
all of the different
rational numbers.
And so whatever rational
number you have,
m over n, that's
going to appear down
the nth row in the nth column.
That number is going to appear.
So they're all going to show up.
And I'm going to use this table
here to fill out this function.
So here are all the
natural numbers.
And the way I'm going to assign
the rational numbers to appear
over here is I'm just going to
work my way in from the corner.
And I'm going to do
that by doing layers.
So first, I'll take
the 1 in this number
here in this corner.
Then, I'll do these
three that surrounded it,
and then these guys
that surround that,
and these guys sort of in shells
going around the previous ones
that I've already covered.
OK, so let me illustrate that.
So here's 1 over 1, my
first rational number
that I'm going to
enter into the table,
appearing right over there.
So next, I'm going
to go 2 over 1.
That's going to appear
in the table over there.
Now, we have 2 over 2.
Now that's actually a little
bit problematic because 2 over 2
has already been done.
And if we put that in--
because 2 over 2
equals 1 over 1.
They're both the equal
to the rational number 1.
So if we put 2 over 2
in this table over here,
then we would no longer
have the one-to-one property
because both 1 and 3 would
be mapping to the same point.
So we're just going to
simply skip over 2 over 2.
I'll show that as kind
of graying it out.
So we're not going to add
that one on to the table
onto my function.
But so we'll skip over that.
We'll go to 1 over 2, which
has not been seen before.
And then we're just going to
continue doing the same thing,
now going to this
next shell out here.
3 over 1, 3 over 2, 3 over 3--
same thing, we're going
to skip over that one--
2 over 3, 1 over 3.
I hope you're getting the idea.
So I'm not going
to fill this table.
I ran out of room to fill
out this table some more.
But just to look at how the
process is going to continue
here, we get 4 over 1.
Now 4 over 2, again, is a
number we previously seen
because that's the
rational number 2.
We saw that up here
when we had 2 over 1,
so we're going to
have to skip that one.
4 over 3, 4 over 4--
that was going to skip.
3 over 4, and so on.
OK?
So by following
this procedure, I'm
going to be able to
define this function.
Now this function
is not particularly
nice in terms of having
an elegant, closed form.
But it is a totally
legitimate function
in the sense of being a
mapping from natural numbers
to the positive
rational numbers.
And it has the one-to-one
correspondence property.
So it pairs up each
of the natural numbers
with each of the positive
rational numbers.
They each get their
own mate, in a sense.
And so that shows that
the rational numbers,
despite the fact
that they're dense,
and they have all sorts of
very more much bigger seeming,
they really, from this
perspective of the sizes
of the sets, they have the same
size as the natural numbers do.
And so with that, it suggests
that the following definition
that a set is
countable if it has
the same size as the natural
numbers or it's finite.
From this perspective,
we're going
to be focusing on infinite sets.
But yeah, countable or countably
infinite, sometimes people say,
if it has the same size
as the natural numbers.
Or otherwise, you have to
include the finite sets
as well.
And countable means you can
just go through the elements
of the set as a list.
So you can count them-- the
first one, the second one,
the third one, the fourth
one, dot, dot, dot.
And once you can do
that, and that counting
is going to hit everything,
then you know can match them--
you can pair them up
with the natural numbers.
And so therefore, you
have a countable set.
OK.
So as we've shown,
both Z, the integers,
and the positive rational
numbers are countable sets.
OK?
Now you might think
that, well, since we're
allowing ourselves
to do something
as arbitrary, in a way,
as this kind of a function
to match up the natural numbers
with whatever set you're trying
to measure, that every set
is going to be countable,
if you think about it that way
because it seems like you're
allowing too many possibilities.
And then all the
infinite sets are
going to end up being the same
size as the natural numbers.
Well, that is, in
fact, is not true.
And I don't know.
Cantor, is the one
who discovered that.
I don't know if that
was surprising or not.
But it is interesting,
I think, that there are
different sizes of infinities.
And so we're going to now
take a look and see that.
But I want to, again,
I want to stop and make
sure we're all together.
Can we always find
a closed formula
for f, somebody's asking me.
I don't know.
For this particular
f, you probably could,
but it would probably
be very messy.
But in general, that's
not a requirement,
having a closed form for
the mapping function.
Any function is allowed as long
as a one-to-one correspondence.
Are we all together on this?
Are we comfortable
with the notion
of some infinite sets
having the same size
as the natural numbers,
and therefore, we're going
to call them countable sets?
And we're going to show
some other sets are
going to have more elements.
They're going to be uncountable.
They're going to be beyond--
strictly speaking, strictly
larger sets in the sense
that we won't be
able to put them
into a one-to-one correspondence
with the integers.
So is N the smallest infinity?
Yes, N is the smallest one.
So any infinity
is going to have--
you're going to always--
I don't think you even need it--
you need a special--
whenever you have an
infinite collection,
you can always
find a subset which
is going to be a
countable subset
and is going to be the
smallest of the infinities,
but there are bigger ones.
All right, why don't we move on?
OK, so the example of a set that
we will show is not countable--
an uncountable set,
as we call it--
is a set of real numbers, which
we all know what these are,
I hope.
These are all of
the numbers that you
can express by possibly
infinite decimal representations
like pi, or E squared of 2, or
any of the other familiar ones.
Rational numbers are also
members of or also count
as real numbers
and integers too.
And so but there are
these additional numbers
that you can get by the
decimal expansions which
may not be rational.
And that collection, even
though, in some ways,
it looks somewhat similar
to the rational numbers,
the real numbers--
I hope I said that right.
The real numbers,
which is the set
I'm considering here, the
ones with the infinite decimal
expansions, they
actually are much larger.
So the theorem is-- and this
was discovered by Cantor--
that R is an uncountable set.
And the reason why
I'm introducing
this is, besides that I think
it's interesting and has
some relation to the kinds
of things we're doing,
but it's really for
the purposes right now,
is to introduce this method
called diagonalization.
OK, that's what we're going
to use later on again.
But this is the first
time it appeared.
So we're going to use a proof
by contradiction in order
to show that R, the
collection of real numbers,
is uncountable.
And we'll assume,
for contradiction,
that R countable.
OK?
So if we assume
that R is countable,
it means we have, by definition,
a one-to-one correspondence
from the natural numbers
to the real numbers.
OK, so we can match up
all of the natural numbers
with the real numbers in a
one-to-one and onto fashion.
So we can pair up the natural
numbers with the real numbers.
And we will cover all of the
real numbers by doing that.
And we can make a table,
just like I did before.
Here it is.
And you can fill this out
with all of the real numbers.
And that was what
the assumption means.
And I'm going to show you
that that's impossible.
Something is going to go
terribly wrong if you do that.
Now you might disagree.
You might be surprised.
You might think,
well, Professor Sipser
is wrong, that I'm going
to work on this overnight
and forget the
rest of my classes,
and I'm going to come up with
a list of all the real numbers.
I'm going to fill
them out here and show
that that's impossible.
So let's say, hypothetically,
just for my example's sake,
here is the list that
you came up with.
So you have to match up
something with the 1.
Let's say, E. That
was a special case,
so you're going to
stick that with 1.
And then pi came
out to be the number
that you connected up with 2.
You understand what
I'm doing here?
I'm making a list.
I'm trying to make my
correspondence-- my matching up
between the natural
numbers and my real numbers
that I'm hypothesizing to
exist for a contradiction.
So 3, I don't know, 3
is gets connected to 0.
I'm making this up, obviously--
not on the spot.
I wrote the slide,
you know, yesterday.
But here is the square root of 2
showing up for whatever reason.
Here is 1/7.
Here is some other number,
which, I'll be interested
if you recognize that one.
That's a subtle one.
This is 1.234-- yeah, some
familiar looking sequence here.
And whatever it is--
whatever it is, this is
what you came up with.
You claim that this
is going to work as--
very good.
Somebody got it.
It's i to the ith power.
But let's not get hung
up on that, please.
I to the ith power,
oddly enough,
can be seen as a
real number under--
if you define the imaginary
exponentiation, which is weird.
But anyway, let's not
get too distracted.
So here's my list of
numbers, my real numbers
that I've matched up in my table
here with the natural numbers.
Now I claim
something goes wrong.
What goes wrong?
I'm going to show you
that you actually did not
do as you claimed,
that there's actually
at least one number that's
missing from this list.
And I'll exhibit that number.
I'm going to show you
what that number is.
I'm going to explicitly
come up with a number
and show you that
there's that number it's
missing from the list.
So here, it's going
to be a number x.
X is the one that's missing.
So how am I going to get x?
So x, well, I'm going to
start it off with 0 point,
and then I'm going to fill
out the rest of the places.
And how am I going
to get those places?
I'm going to look
at the table here.
So I want to look at--
to get my first digit after
the decimal point of x,
I'm going to look
at the first digit
after the decimal point
of the very first number.
So I take the first number,
look at the first digit
after the decimal point,
which happens to be a 7.
And the number I'm
going to put in for x
It's not going to be 7.
It's going to be
anything except 7.
Let say, 8.
For my next digit of x,
I'm going to look at--
so my second digit
of x, I'm going to--
everything's going to be
up to the decimal point
now, so I'm not going
to keep saying that.
I'm going to look
at the second digit
of the second number, which is
a 4 after the decimal point.
There it is.
And for the second
digit of x, I'm
going to use something which
is anything besides 4--
5.
I have some flexibility here.
So I could have used 6.
I could have used 7.
For those of you who
have seen this before,
who are going to
nitpick on me, I'm
going to stay away from 9
and 0 just because there
is some little edge cases that
arise there, which I don't want
to get into because
I don't think it's
interesting for this argument.
But since I have
some flexibility,
I'm going to avoid
zeros and nines--
probably just nines
is all I really need.
And then the argument is
just going to work fine, OK?
So the next digit is a 0.
The third digit, or the
third number is a 0.
The third digit of x is going
to be anything except for 0.
It could be a 1.
Then I have a 2 here.
Anything except a 2, 6.
Then a 5-- anything
except a 5, a 1.
A 9-- anything except
a 9, an 8, and so on.
There's an 8.
There's a 2, and dot, dot, dot.
I'm just going to
keep doing that.
And I'm going to say you missed
that number, whatever it is.
But that number,
that's a number.
After I'm all done,
it's going to be
the decimal representation
of something.
And that number, I claim,
is absent from the table.
And you might say,
well, it's really there.
It's just on the 23rd row.
You just didn't get
to it and your slide.
But it's there.
Well, I'm going to say I
know it's not in the 23rd row
because it differs from
the number in the 23rd row
at the 23rd digit because
I constructed it that way.
This number is
designed explicitly
to be different from each of
the numbers that's on the list.
So it can't be on
the list because it's
been constructed to be
different from each of them
in at least one place.
So I think this is a
beautiful argument,
and it shows that
no matter how you
try to come up with a
one-to-one correspondence,
you're going to fail.
You might say, oh,
like, just one number?
I did so much hard work.
I'm missing just one number.
Can't I get partial credit
and put this one on the list
now I fixed it?
No.
Obviously, there are many,
many numbers that are missing.
If you put this
one on the list, I
was going to construct another
number that was missing.
So there's just not no
possibility of fixing this.
And in fact, the real
numbers are uncountable--
cannot be matched up
with the natural numbers.
And there's nothing.
It doesn't even come close.
So here, a summary
of what I just said.
F is not a one-to-one
correspondence
no matter what you try to do.
You can't come up with a
one-to-one correspondence.
That's the contradiction.
So that proves that
R is uncountable.
And that's why, by the way,
we call this a diagonalization
because we're going
down this diagonal here
that's where the term-- that's
where the name is come from.
OK, so I'm happy to--
[CHUCKLES] OK, that's a--
somebody's asking me--
[CHUCKLES] I'm actually--
I have a-- is it here?
I can't remember if it's here.
I have a check-in
coming about this.
And somebody is
anticipating that
by asking the actually rather
famous question about there
being a possible infinity in
between the natural numbers
and the real numbers.
We know the real
numbers now are bigger
than the natural numbers.
But is there something
that's an in between?
I mean, this is a very,
very famous problem,
which I'll talk about when
we get to our check-in, which
is coming up.
Somebody is objecting
just the way
I've defined x using
this procedure that
really can't, in a sense, state,
you know-- but x is a number.
X is the result of
what this procedure is.
Following this procedure,
we're converging
on some particular value.
And so that is a value.
If you want, we can make a more
precise way of determining.
We don't have the
flexibility of choosing
the way I did in my example.
We can make a precise
procedure for coming up
with these digits.
But I don't think there's
anybody thinks there's anything
that's--
there's any shortcoming
in this argument in terms
of the way we're defining x.
I think it's worth understanding
this because it's really going
to set the groundwork for our
proof that A,TM is undecidable,
which is a little,
I think, perhaps,
slightly more abstract in a
way in the way it sort of comes
across.
I'm going to try
to connect the two.
But I think it's
helpful to understand
at least this argument
because this argument is
diagonalization in
its most raw form.
All right, I think we're good.
So why don't we continue, then?
So there are a
number of corollaries
that follow from the statement
that the real numbers is
uncountable.
First of all, if
you let script L
be the collection
of all languages,
if you want to consider it
over some particular alphabet,
that's fine.
But that's not going to be
really important for this point
that I'm going to make.
So script L is the
collection of all languages.
So every subset of sigma star--
every subset of sigma
star is a language.
So look at all those
possible subsets.
So that includes 0
to the k, 1 to the k,
plus every other language you
can ever think of and more--
all possible languages.
So the collection of all
languages is uncountable.
There's uncountably many
different languages out there.
I don't want to
belabor this point.
You can just take this
if you don't quite
follow the quick argument
I'm going to make here.
But you can make a
one-to-one correspondence
from all languages to the
reals so that each language
gets its own real number.
And the way I'm going to
think about that-- let's
put the real numbers
into binary form.
And if you imagine
here being sigma star,
all of the possible
strings of sigma
star written out in
their standard order.
And now if you have
a language here, A,
it's just some
arbitrary language.
So that's going to have some
of the strings of sigma star
appearing.
Like 0 is appearing,
but 1 is not appearing.
00 is appearing and 01,
but not these three.
And I'm going to associate
to A, my language,
some real number in binary by
putting in a 0 in the decimal
representation-- well,
the binary representation,
I should say--
for that string if it's not
there and a 1 if it is there.
And so a real number--
because there's infinitely
many yes/no choices in
the binary representation
can represent a
language because of each
of the yes/no choices of a
string being present or not.
I'm going to put a 1 for
when the string is present,
a 0 when it's not present.
So each language has
its own real number,
and each real number
is going to be
associated to its own language.
Here, I'm restricting myself to
real numbers between 0 and 1.
That's not going to
be an essential point.
So let's not get
hung up on that.
So the fact that the
languages can be putting it
into a one-to-one correspondence
with the real numbers
shows that the collection of all
languages is also uncountable.
Now another observation here--
another point worth noting is
that if you look at sigma star
itself, the strings,
all possible strings,
that's a countable set.
The collection of all possible
languages is uncountable.
But the collection of all
possible finite strings
is countable because
I can just list them.
Here's my list of all
possible strings, which
you can put into a
table if you like
to think of it matching up
with the natural numbers
in that way.
Now I'm trying to
make a point here,
which is that if you take M,
which is all possible Turing
machines-- script M
is all possible Turing
machines-- the collection of
all possible Turing machines
is countable.
There are only countably many
different Turing machines.
And you can argue that in all
sorts of messy different ways.
But I think the most
simple way to see
that is to think about
each Turing machine
as having a description,
which is a string.
So the collection of all
descriptions of Turing machines
is just a subset of sigma
star, which we already
know is countable.
And the subset of any countable
set is going to be countable.
So anyway, I think
it's worth remembering
that the collection of old
Turing machines is countable.
Whereas the collection of
all languages is uncountable.
And that tells you right there
that some language is not
decided because there are more
languages than Turing machines.
We've unaccountably
many language, only
countably many Turing machines,
so that's fewer Turing machines
than languages.
There's no way to map all the
languages onto Turing machines.
So there's going to always
be some languages that
got unmapped.
And so, in particular,
there are going
to be some languages
which are undecidable.
There are going to be
some languages which
are not Turing-recognizable.
And anything based on some
automata kind of a definition
process is going to be some
languages that they're not
going to be defined.
OK, now what this
corollary shows you
that there is some language out
there, which is not decidable.
What we're going to
show next is that there
is a specific language--
A,TM-- which is not decidable.
And but first, I think we
have a check-in coming up.
And let me give you a
little bit of background
here because this is
relevant to this question
that I got about
intermediate size sets.
So the question of
whether there is
a set of size between
the natural numbers
and the real numbers
strictly in between--
so bigger than the natural
numbers, not the same size
as the natural numbers,
but not the same size
as the real numbers either,
but in between in size.
That was Hilbert's question
number 1 out of his list of 23
that I talked about
a few lectures back.
It's interesting that he put
it as number 1 in that very
privileged special place because
I know Hilbert was very--
he felt that the
understanding infinity
was a really central
issue in mathematics.
And that if we can't answer
a question like this,
we don't really
understand infinity.
You want to understand what
kind of sizes of infinities
are there.
We know there's the
real number is bigger
than the natural numbers.
Is there something in between?
So fundamental, really.
But it was shown during the
course of the 20th century,
really, in two separate steps--
one in the 1930s by Godel,
one in the early
1970s by Cohen--
that we can't
answer this question
by using the standard
axioms of mathematics.
The answer can go either way.
And both of them are consistent
with the axes mathematics.
So you're never going
to be able to prove
that there is a set
whose size is in between
or that there is no such set.
It's just impossible to
prove either way using
the standard axiom of
mathematics, which, actually,
is kind of remarkable.
And so my question for you
is-- and this is really
a philosophical question,
not one that is directly you
need to know about
material in the course.
I think it's just a matter
of your own interest.
I hope you find it interesting.
If you don't, you can
just answer it randomly.
But what's going on here
that we can't answer
that question
about whether there
is a set of intermediate size?
Is it because our axioms for
mathematics are inadequate?
Or maybe there is no such thing
as a mathematical reality.
You can talk about
what's real here?
What's the reality?
Either there is a set
in between or not.
If you can imagine,
all of these things
have their own reality
to them, well, then,
there's going to be an answer.
And then you would
expect, well, maybe
we can find better axioms,
which will actually
give us that answer.
Or you can say, well,
there is no reality.
And infinite sets are
kind of human constructs
anyway, so we can make them kind
of play out any way we like.
Mathematicians argue
about that to this day.
And it is, as I say, really,
it's a philosophical question.
But just out of curiosity,
let's see how you guys end up
deciding on that one.
So here is the poll.
5 seconds to go.
Please vote.
And we're going to end
the polling, 1, 2, 3, now.
All right, here we go.
So there's no right answer.
I think if most mathematicians
were to, I think,
the instinct of most
logicians, especially, I'm
not sure if general
mathematicians really even care
about this question, but
logicians would probably
have an instinct that, probably,
there are sets in between.
There's no reason that
there shouldn't be.
It seems kind of
strange that there
should be this sort of jump
from the natural numbers
to the real numbers and
why nothing in between?
But I don't think that
question is really settled.
All right, let's continue on.
I think we are--
OK, so we're going to--
our coffee break is coming,
in case you're wondering.
So this is my last
slide before then.
But this is an important
slide, so please hold out.
So here is our promised
theorem of the day.
I'm going to show that
A,TM is not decidable,
the acceptance problem
for Turing machines.
And it's all going to be
contained on this one slide.
We're going to give a
proof by contradiction
using diagonalization.
And we're going to assume
some Turing machine, H,
decides A,TM.
And we're going to
get a contradiction.
So let's, first of
all, make sure we
understand what H is doing.
So H gets an input--
a Turing machine and an input.
And H is going to be a
decider, so it always
halts with an
accept or a reject.
It's supposed to accept if
M accepts w and reject if it
doesn't.
So in other words,
it's going to reject
if M rejects w either by
halting or by looping.
That's the job of H. And
we're assuming we can do that.
But we will see a
contradiction occur.
So the way we're going to do
that is really kind of just one
step here in a way.
And we're going to use H
to construct another Turing
machine D. H is going to be a
subroutine to D. We've already
seen us doing that in the past.
D is going to do something
a little strange,
just to warn you.
D's input is just
a Turing machine--
no w.
And what D is going to
do using its subroutine
H is going to simulate H on
input M, comma, the description
of M. Now what is that?
Well, the description of
M is just some string.
So what H is trying--
what it's asking H to
tell, to answer is,
does M accept the
string representing
M's own description?
It's as if we're
feeding M into itself,
which seems like a totally
twisted thing to do,
you might say.
Why would you ever feed
a program into itself?
Somebody has written
cannibalism here--
yeah, kind of.
I'd say it's worse
[LAUGHS] because it's not
eating somebody else.
It's eating yourself.
OK, but I claim that there are
actual cases in practice where
we do this.
We feed programs
into themselves.
And the example that I
know of where this is done
is when you're
making a compiler.
You might want to
make a compiler
and then written in the same
language that it's compiling.
And then you feed the
compiler into itself.
You may say, why even
bother because it's already,
obviously, if it,
once it's running,
you don't need to
compile it again.
But actually, an example
where this was really used
was when there was an
optimizing compiler, I think,
for C written on
early Unix machines.
And the optimizing compiler
for C was written in C.
So you would feed the
optimizing compiler
into the regular
compiler, first of all.
Now, you had the
compiler running,
but it was an optimized.
So but now that it's the
optimizing compiler is running,
you can feed the
optimizing compiler
into that, which is itself.
Now you have an optimized
optimizing compiler.
So it really makes some--
there is at least one case
where this has actually
been done in practice.
Not that we really care.
This is a theory class-- but
just for fun to observe that.
So here, H is trying to
say, well, does in a M end
up accepting when it's fed
the description of itself?
You know, at least,
mathematically speaking,
that's a reasonable
thing to ask.
And then what D is going to do
when it gets the answer back
from H--
H is a decider, don't forget--
is D's going to do the
opposite of whatever H does.
It's going to
accept if H rejects
and reject if H accepts.
So let's, in summary,
let's pull this together,
so it's easy to understand,
in the end, what is D doing?
D is going to accept.
D is also going to be
decider, by the way.
So D is always going to
either accept or reject--
Just.
The opposite of what
H tells it to do.
So D is going to accept M
exactly when M doesn't accept M
because when M doesn't accept
M, H is going to reject,
and so then D is
going to accept.
So D accepts M if and
only if M doesn't accept
M. That's exactly the
condition in which D accepts
M. I think it's important to
just step back and make sure
you understand this line
because we have only one line
left to get our contradiction.
Right?
Are we together?
D accepts M if and
only if M doesn't
accept M. That's just by the
way we've defined setup D.
Now what we're going to do is
feed in, instead of M to D,
and not some arbitrary feed,
we're going to use feed in D
into D. And that is going
to be our contradiction
because D is now
going to accept D if
and only if D doesn't
accept D, and that's
certainly impossible.
That's our contradiction which
proves that H cannot exist.
And therefore, A,TM
is undecidable.
OK, so we're done,
except for the one
point, which is that why
is this a diagonalization?
And I think you can get that
from the following picture.
If you imagine here writing
down all possible times--
I'm going to make a table here.
Here is the list of
all Turing machines,
including D, which
is a machine which
I built under the
assumption that H exists.
So D appears here somewhere.
But here are all the
other Turing machines.
And here are all of these
descriptions of the Turing
machines along the labeling
all of the columns.
OK, so these are
the rows labeled.
These are the column labels.
And inside, I'm
going to tell you
the answer for whether a given
machine accepts a given input.
So for example, M1 accepts
its own description
but rejects the
description of M2,
but accepts the
description of M3.
I don't you know.
I'm obviously I'm
making this up.
I don't know what M1 is.
But just hypothetically, that's
what the machine M1 does.
So I'm just filling
out this table.
H could get the answer to any
of the elements in this table
because it can test whether M4
accepts the description of M3.
So H could fill out this table.
So maybe M2 is a machine
that always rejects.
It's a very unfriendly,
rejecting machine.
M3 is a very friendly machine.
It accepts all inputs.
M4 rejects some and accepts
others, dot, dot, dot.
Now, I want to look and
see, what does D do?
Now based on the information
that I've already given you,
we can understand what D does.
So for example, what
does D do when I
feed it the description of M1?
What does D do?
Well, we can look here.
D accepts M if and only
if M doesn't accept M. So
D is going to accept M1 if and
only if M1 does not accept M1.
Well, M1 does accept M1.
So D does the opposite.
D rejects.
So OK, I'm highlighting here.
D rejects because
D is going to do
the opposite of what the machine
does on its own it on input.
So D on M2, you have to
look what M2 does on M2.
It rejects, so D does
the opposite of that.
It accepts.
And similarly, each
one of these things--
D's answer is going to
be the opposite of what
the machine does on
its own description,
just by virtue of the
definition of D. OK, and so on--
so far, so good.
But the problem is, what
happens when D is fed itself?
Because, as you can see,
we're heading for trouble
because this is a
diagonal down here.
D is just one of the rows.
That diagonal is going
to intersect that row
at this point.
And D is defined to be going to
be doing the opposite of what
that element is, but it can't
be the opposite of itself.
And so that's the contradiction.
So I think we're--
I'm going to call us, give
us a little break here.
And then you can also
text me in the meantime.
I'll be happy to answer
some questions during that.
A little over 4 minutes
to go-- so let's see.
Let me see if I can
answer your questions.
OK, what's so special about
A,TM that enables us to do this?
Why can't we do this
on ADFA, for example?
That's a good question.
And the answer is that, in a
sense, we can do this on DFA.
I mean, I think this is,
perhaps, a bit of a stretch.
But DFAs could not answer ADFA.
I mean, we could prove that in
other ways as well by just--
we could use things
like the pumping lemma,
and it's not clear, even
how you'd formulate ADFA.
But what's important
here is that it's really
the model talking about
itself that really
is where the problem comes up.
So if you try to push
this argument through
to show that ADFA is not
decidable by Turing machines,
you're going to fail
because we're starting off
with a Turing machine.
And I think I'm going
to confuse myself
if I try to just repeat it.
But you won't get
a contradiction
because the Turing machine
is not a finite automaton.
OK.
Will this argument
get into self-loops?
I don't see why it would--
there is some self-reference,
perhaps.
We're going to talk about
that a little later.
So we're going to come back and
revisit this argument in a week
or so when we talk about
the recursion theorem which
talks about machines that
can refer to themselves.
But this is a little
bit of a head--
getting ahead of ourselves.
So somebody's commenting
on this reminding them
of the barber paradox,
if you remember that,
which has some similarity.
There is a town
in which there was
a barber which shaves every man
who doesn't shave themselves.
It seems he's a
very good barber.
So there are some people
who shave themselves.
And all the rest,
the barber shaves.
The question is, does
the barber shave himself?
Because he shaves only those
men who don't shave themselves.
So you've got a same
kind of a contradiction.
There is a relationship there.
So someone wants to know, where
did we use the decidability?
So we used the decidability
to come up with H.
Once we know that
A,TM is decidable,
then we have that H function,
and then we can build D.
So that's the chain of reason.
So you assume A,TM is decidable.
Then you have the
decider called H,
and then you can build
D. Somebody wants
to see the previous slide.
What part of the
slide do you want?
So I'll leave that up there.
Why can we apply the proof
that all Turing machines are
accountable to all languages?
Well, because Turing
machines have descriptions.
General languages don't
have descriptions.
And so that's why.
OK, the candle has
burnt to the bottom,
and it's time to move on.
So now, let's look at
the acceptance problem
for queue automata.
I'll give you a queue automaton
on input, and I want to know,
does it accept the input?
Is that going to be decidable?
And you have your choices.
It's either yes, it is
decidable because these
are similar to pushdown
automata and APDA is decidable,
or no because yes
contradicts results
that we know at
this point, or we
don't have enough information
to answer the question.
OK, let's put that up.
One second-- [LAUGHS]
all right, that's it.
Ready, going, gone.
So yes, the answer is, well, no.
[LAUGHS] The answer
is, indeed, the answer
is B. True, that
queue automata are
similar to pushdown automata,
but all these automata
are similar to each
other, and that's not
going to be good enough.
What the homework
has asked you to do
is to show that you
can simulate Turing
machines with queue automata.
So if you can
answer the question
about whether the queue automata
will accept their input,
that would allow you to be
able to answer questions
about whether Turing
machines accept their input.
And we just proved
that's not possible.
So it would be a contradiction
if we could answer--
if we could decide A, queue, A.
Now, we have an example of
an undecidable language.
Let's look at an example of
an unrecognizable language.
Now A,TM is not going to serve
that purpose because A,TM is
Turing-recognizable, as we
pointed out by the universal
Turing machine.
So A,TM is undecidable, however.
How about an
unrecognizable language?
For that, we will see that the
complement of A,TM will serve.
So the complement of A,TM is
neither decidable nor even
recognizable.
Now it's not
Turing-recognizable.
And that's going to follow from
a pretty basic theorem that
connects recognizability and
decidability that I've put up
here on the screen,
which is that if you have
a language where it
and its complement
are both recognizable, then
the language turnout turns out
to be decidable.
In fact, a language and its
complement are decidable.
But being decidable is
closed under complement,
so that's something
you should be aware.
But being-- OK.
We'll get to that in a minute.
But if-- so anyway, so
if you have a language
and it's complement
both recognizable,
how do we know the
language is decidable?
So first of all, let's take
the two Turing machines,
M1 and M2 that recognizes
A and A-complement.
And we're going to
put those together
to get a decider for A. And
that's going to work like this.
It's going to be
called T. So T says,
on input w, what
it's going to do,
it's going to feed w
into M1 and M2 both.
A is the language,
by the way, yes.
A is-- when I say it's
Turing-recognizable,
you know, Turing-recognizable
only applies to languages.
So yes, A is often this symbol
I'm going to use for languages,
sometimes for an automaton.
But A is typically
going to be a language.
So now, I'm trying to
make T be a decider for A
from the recognizers
for A and A-complement.
So I'm going to
take an input to T
and feed it into both
recognizers, M1 and M2.
OK, I'm going to run
them in parallel.
What's nice is that
because M2 recognizes
the complement of
what M1 recognizes,
every string is going to be
accepted either by M1 or by M2
because every string is either
an A or an A-complement.
So if I run M1 and M2 on w until
one of the halts or one of them
accepts, I know I'm not
going to run forever
because, eventually, one or
the other one have to accept.
So and then I got my answer
because if M1 accepts,
then I know I'm in the language.
But if M2 accepts, I know I'm in
the complement of the language,
so I'm out of the language.
So if M1 accepts,
then T should accept.
But if M2 accepts,
then T should reject. ,
So that proves that nice little
theorem written at the top
in blue.
So I got my decider
for A built out
of the recognizers for
A and A-complement.
Now immediately, it follows that
the complement of A,TM is not
Turing-recognizable because
we know that A,TM itself is
recognizable, but
it's undecidable.
If the complement was
also recognizable,
then A,TM would be
decidable, but it isn't.
So when something is decidable,
either it or its complement
have to be unrecognizable.
And in the case for A,TM, it has
to be the complement because we
already showed that it is
itself is recognizable.
So that's the proof of that.
So here is a little
picture of the way
the world looks right now if
you have here, in the middle are
the decidable languages--
so these are all
languages, this Venn
diagram of languages.
We showed earlier, the regular,
the context-free, decidable,
recognizable.
Here, I've got the recognizable
and what I'm calling
the co-Turing recognizable.
This is the collection
of all complements
of recognizable languages.
So A,TM bar, A,TM
complement is the complement
of a recognizable language.
This region here are
all the complements
of the recognizable languages
or the so-called co-Turing
recognizable languages--
complement of.
So A,TM is on this side.
A,TM-complement is on that side.
But if something's in both, by
virtue of this theorem here,
then it's decidable.
OK, last check-in for the day.
From what we learned so far,
which closure properties
can we prove for the
class of deterring
recognizable languages?
Choose all that apply.
Well, as I say, you don't
have to get it right.
Let's not spend too
much more time on this
because we'll talk a
little bit about it.
Almost all-- its closed
under almost all of them,
but not all of them.
Because-- are we done here?
I think we're done--
5 seconds.
OK, here we go, ending polling.
I'm not sure what the meaning
of [LAUGHS] deleting your answer
is here.
Everybody likes union, I guess.
They're closed under
all of these operations
except complement.
But we just proved it's not
closed under complement,
so I'm a little puzzled by
why we have so many votes
for closure under complement.
We have here, A,TM is
Turing-recognizable,
but A,TM-complement is
not Turing-recognizable.
it's right here on the slide.
I'm not trying to
make you feel bad,
but I'm trying to just point
out that you think, please.
So now closure under union
and intersection, I mean,
you could kind of
get those answers
just by running things
in parallel the way
we did the proof here.
You just run both machines.
And if they both give--
I mean, it's a little
tricky, I suppose.
If either one of them
accept, then you can accept.
Or if they both
accept, you just wait
until they both have accepted.
Otherwise, you
just keep running.
So the first two are
pretty straightforward.
Closure under
concatenation-- this
is also going to be similar.
You just try every possible
way of cutting the string up
into two pieces and
run in parallel on.
And if you ever find a
way of cutting it up,
and you run those two, and put
those two sides in parallel,
and if they both accept,
then you can accept.
And star is, again,
very similar.
So these are not too bad.
But I admit, you know, it's
not a whole lot of time
to have to contend with
something that you're just
getting used to.
So let's talk about the very
last topic of the day, which
is really going to be setting
ourselves up for Tuesday's
lecture next week.
And that's how we are going to
be showing other languages are
undecidable, which is something
that I'm going to be expecting
you guys to be able to do.
This is the standard
procedure for showing
languages are
undecidable using what's
called the reducibility method.
And what that does is it
takes, as a starting point,
a language that we already
know is undecidable--
typically, A,TM-- or it
could be another one that
you've previously shown
to be undecidable--
and leverages that information
to show other languages are
undecidable.
And it's using what's
called reducibility.
We're going to go into this
more carefully next time.
But basically,
reducibility is a way
of using one problem to
solve another problem.
And so we are going to
show, for example, let's
take a look at
the problem called
the halting problem, which
is like the famous problem
for Turing machines.
You just want to know whether
it halts, not necessarily
whether it accepts.
So it's very similar,
but not exactly the same.
And we're going to show
that this halting problem is
similarly undecidable.
Now we could go back and do
the whole diagonalization,
but that seems like--
well, that's more work than
necessary now that we already
know A,TM is undecidable because
we're going to show that we can
reduce the A,TM problem
to the halting problem.
And we'll explain what
that means again later.
But the idea is-- and as
we'll show in an illustration
shortly--
that by proving by contradiction
if the if HALT,TM were
decidable, then A,TM
would be decided.
And we know A,TM
is not decidable.
And so that's our contradiction.
Now the way we're going to show
that if HALT,TM is decidable,
then A,TM is decidable is use
a decider for HALT,TM to decide
A,TM with a suitable
modification.
So basically, we want to turn
a HALT,TM decider into an A,TM
decider.
And that's how we're going to
reduce the problem of solving
A,TM to the problem
of solving HALT,TM.
Let's just do an example.
If you've seen it
before, obviously, this
is not going to be hard.
But for the many of you who
have not seen it before,
I'm partly doing it this time
just so we can do it again
next time.
And maybe it'll sink in
by virtue of repetition.
So again, so as I just
said, we're going to assume
the HALT,TM problem is decidable
and use that to show that A,TM
is decidable, which
we know is false.
We showed it just
earlier that it's not.
So assume we have a
decider for HALT,TM.
We'll call it R. And we're going
to construct from R a decider
for A,TM we'll call S. OK?
So we're, again, typical
proof by contradiction.
We're assuming the opposite
of what we're trying to prove.
And then we're going
to get something crazy.
OK, so here, my job now,
is I'm assuming I have R,
which is a HALT,TM decider.
So now, I'm assuming
I know how to decide
if a Turing machine and an
input eventually halts--
Not.
Necessarily would it accept,
just whether it halts.
It's conceivable.
You have to bear with me here.
It's conceivable that
you could find a way
to test whether Turing
machines halt on their input,
even though we now know that
testing whether they accept
their input is not decidable.
So you have to be open-minded
to the possibility
that the HALT
problem is decidable,
and we're going to show
that that's can't be.
So we're going to show that
if we could decide the halting
problem, then we can use that to
decide the acceptance problem.
OK, so how are we
going to do that?
So imagine how we can
solve the halting problem.
So to solve the A,TM, which
is what my job is to do,
so S is supposed to solve A,TM.
I'm constructing a Turing
machine as decide A,TM.
I'm going to use first--
I'm giving it M and w.
I'm going to feed it into R
since that's really all I got.
See if R tells me what happens.
Does M on w at least halt?
Well, if R says,
no, it doesn't halt,
well then I'm actually done
because if M doesn't even
halt on w, then it
couldn't be accepting w.
So at that point, I know
that M doesn't accept w,
and I can reject right off.
So R, you can see how it
could potentially be helpful.
But it's going to be
helpful in either way
because if R says M
does hold, well, then,
I'm also good because I
don't know the answer yet,
but what I do know is I
can now simulate M on w
until it halts because
R has told me it halts.
So I don't have to worry
about getting into a loop.
So S can be confident in being
a decider for whatever it's
doing because I'm running
now M on w with a guarantee
that it halts.
And now, that's going to
tell me-- now eventually,
the simulation of M on w is
going to end up at an accept
or reject.
And that's going to
be the answer I need.
So if M is accepted,
then accept.
And if M is rejected,
then reject.
And that's how S solves A,TM
using R, which solves HALT,TM.
But S can't exist.
And so therefore, R can't exist.
And therefore, HALT,TM
can't be decidable.
OK?
So that quickly--
OK, I'm not sure which
diagram you wanted me to show.
But anyway, maybe
we can do that.
We're basically at the end
of the hour or end of the 90
minutes.
So let's do a quick review.
And if you stick around, I'm
happy to go back and look
at any of the other slides that
you might have missed something
on.
OK, so just to recap, we
showed that the natural numbers
and the real numbers are not the
same size using that definition
of one-to-one correspondence to
introduce the diagonalization
method.
We used the diagonalization
method to show that A,TM is
undecidable.
We also showed
that little theorem
that if the language
and its complement
are recognizable, then
the language is decidable.
And from that, we concluded
that A,TM complement is not
recognizable.
And then we showed, at least
by virtue of an introduction
to the method, the reducibility
method to show that HALT,TM is
undecidable.
And that was today's lecture.
And we're and we're at
the end of the hour.
So why don't I--
we are finished.
You can log out.
And if you want, I
will stick around.
OK, OK, this is kind of
a good question here.
So I'm getting a question about
the A,TM-complement, which is--
since we have a
recognizer for A,TM,
if I'm doing justice
to this question,
we have a recogniser for A,TM,
so why can't we just invert
the answer?
Flip the answer around, and
now, we have a recognizer
for the complement of
A,TM, A,TM-complement.
So why doesn't that work?
Well, the reason that doesn't
work is because the recognizer
for A,TM might be rejecting
some things by looping.
And now, if you just flip
the accepting and rejecting,
when it hits one of
those halting states,
it's going to give
the reverse answer.
But when it rejects
by looping, it'll
continue to reject by looping.
So you won't get the
complementary language
coming out.
So if it would be helpful, I
can go back to that slide here,
which proves that
A,TM-complement is
unrecognizable because maybe we
should start with the bottom.
We know that A,TM is
recognizable and undecidable,
right?
We already proved
those two facts.
A,TM is recognizable from
the universal Turing machine,
and it's undecidable by the
diagonalization argument.
Those two things
together tell us
that the complement has
to be unrecognizable
because if a language
and its complement
are both recognizable-- and
we already know the language
itself is recognizable.
So now, if the complement
is also recognizable,
the language is going to be
decidable by the upper theorem.
So it must be the case had
either the language itself
is unrecognizable, or its
complement is unrecognizable.
We know the language
is recognizable.
That's what the universal
Turing machine told us.
So the only thing left
is for the complement
to be unrecognizable.
You should review that
if you didn't get it
because this is the
kind of reasoning
we're going to be building
on things like that.
So I think it's good to
make sure you understand.
OK.
OK, the diagram on
the right-- so this
is just a Venn diagram here.
I threw this in at
the last minute here.
I was worried about
it being confusing.
That part is--
I'm trying to show that the
three classes that we've
already talked about--
the languages which
are decidable,
the languages which are
Turing-recognizable,
and the languages
whose complements
are Turing-recognizable.
Those are three separate
classes of languages.
And those come up here
in those three regions.
These are the decidable ones.
Here are the recognizable ones.
And here are the ones whose
complements are recognizable.
Now if a language is in
both the recognizable,
and its complement
is recognizable--
so it's in both of these
bigger regions here--
then this theorem tells
you it's decidable.
So that's why the intersection
of these two regions
is marked as being
decidable because that
means you're in both.
OK?
But we know that A,TM is
sitting out here as recognizable
but not decidable.
So A,TM is in the
recognizable side,
but it's not on the complement
of recognizable, A,TM itself.
The complement of A,TM is the
complement of a recognizable
but itself is not recognizable
and not decidable.
So you got this side
of nice, you know--
I hope you think
it's nice, but it's
sort of a try to summarize
things in this little Venn
diagram.
So I think I'm going
to then sign off.
And I'll see you all on Tuesday.
And have a good weekend.
Bye bye.